memory. All
right, I'm happy enough with this to
merge it.
Hey,
bet. Which of these do I keep? There's
no Syon,
right? Yeah, there's no Syon. So, we
just do this.
Oh no, there is the cart
pull. There's siphon for cart pull. So
we keep this one. We get rid of this
one. And that's
it. I just want to get this through. And
I want to I just want to run for lunch
real
quick. Get to
merge. Stop it. Stop
it. All right.
Why is it this
big? The window is
huge. Compilation stuff takes a uh
that's just it caching, man. That's
because of the new CUDA stuff, I think.
Don't worry about that.
We do kind of want off white for that,
don't we?
That took me all five seconds, right? Is
there any reason for it to be this large
of a screen in
bet? I mean, I'll let you deal with
that, but I'll just give you this for
now.
No
reason. Yeah. Try to like get them into
like reasonable sizes and aspect ratios
so we can put them on the website
nicely. You know, it's going to go here
with the rest of
them. I mean, technically it can go
here, but it'll look better in like a
reasonable ratio.
You got to keep the width the same as
the original, but it's about
Yeah. So, with the bigger
games, the standard for these, I believe
I do
720p. Uh, well, it depends on the ratio,
right? like this has a certain number of
tiles by a certain number of tiles, but
this should be
720p, which is 720 1080. That's the
biggest I go. And then I do like the
smaller 4x3s often. I mean, some of
these are games that have like their own
predefined aspect ratio, but you know,
they're all kind of a reasonable size if
you look at
This is 720p as well, right? So, the
ones that can be 720p usually
are.
Anyways, thank you for breakout that I
mean uh for pull that seems nice. I'm
sure that this thing cran
funny. Doesn't actually get all the way
to the top cleanly
termination. You did not include a score
variable though. You should include a
score variable.
nicely. What happens if I just do
uh Oh, you didn't set the optimizer
weird on this.
Interesting. All
right. Well, I'm going to call it a
night. I got to get some rest. Tomorrow
we'll be working on more stuff. I guess
the only other thing I want to do is
make sure that this run is crashed
immediately. Yeah. So, that's down
there. Little different already.
useful. Oh,
yeah. It's kind of a weird shape. We'll
see if it takes off or not, but uh
that's something.
All
right, let's see. Does the channel even
show
anything? I guess the channel does show
a couple people. So, the folks watching,
I'll be streaming Devil all day
tomorrow. Um, just got to get some
sleep. But all my stuff's at
puffer.ai. You want to help us out?
Free, start the repo. Really helps us
out. We're almost at 2K.
And uh if you want to get involved with
dev, join the discord. Some of our best
contributors came in with zero RL
experience. Really just need a basic
programming
background. And you can follow me on X
for more RL content. Got a blog with a
nice quick start guide and a few other
things, but there's more stuff on X.
Thanks. And I will be